Professor Noveck
is Florence Rogatz
visiting professor and
director of The Governance Lab
at Yale Law school.
She's the Jerry Hultin
Global Network Professor
at New York University's
Tandon School of Engineering
and director of the GovLab
lab and its MacArthur Research
Network on opening governance.
Professor Noveck
focuses her research,
teaching, and activism on
the impact of technology
on public institutions and
solving public problems.
A graduate of Harvard
University and Yale Law School--
welcome home-- she is a
member of the advisory board
of the open
contracting partnership
and is program committee
member of the 2016
conferences on
international open data,
open data research, data
science for government,
and the data for good exchange.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Let's see, do I
have a deck here?
[APPLAUSE]
No, no, no.
We'll just change that.
I have this for other reasons.
I'll tell you what, I'll start
while if you don't mind bring--
no.
I'll let you put my deck
up and that way we'll--
so I am-- let me start--
it's under Noveck, I
hope, or somewhere--
by saying I am
delighted to be here.
And I'm here first
and foremost just
to meet the people in
the room and to enjoy
the fellowship of people
who have so much in common.
And also to report--
because it wasn't on the
list that was up earlier--
that we now have an open data
clinic at Yale Law School
as well, where we
have lots of students
working on and eager
to work on open data
related policy projects.
So I'm here a little bit
as the lawyer in the room--
don't all now leave
at once-- but to talk
about the legal and
ethical and policy side
of some of this work.
Again, there's a
lot that has already
been covered so I will
try not to repeat unduly.
But I want to pick up
on a point that was
made earlier perhaps in jest.
So I was the head
of open government
and open data at
OSTP, so you have
me to blame for some of
those unfunded mandates.
And the throw away
comment that you
made about the end of open
science and open government
and open data in
the White House,
I want to make sure to
bring that back to the fore.
Because though it was funny, as
we know it's really not funny.
And so I want to make sure
that we're at least focused on
and the one thing that
we take away from this
is that as much as we're
excited about the technologies
of big data, as much as we're
eager to talk as we will today,
and as the students
showed yesterday
about the many important things
we can do with the data that's
available, it's not simply
the tools that are making
possible everything
we're talking about,
it's the policies
that underlie them.
And that obviously runs
through the conversation.
So it's the fact that we now
have a policy of open data
at the national level
in the United States
and that next week,
70 countries will
meet for the Open Government
Partnership in Paris.
70 countries who have
signed on to commitments
to open up their data, to create
data portals at the national,
at the state, at
the local level.
15 of those countries
have now signed on
to an international
open data charter which
they are making commitments--
what I'm looking for is
the exact language which
I won't find at the moment--
in which they are going to
make commitments to essentially
publish all data
in digital format,
downloadable, open to
the public a apriori.
So, we still have a long way
to go to realize the vision,
but at least we have the
cornerstone in terms of policy
that started with President
Obama's memorandum
on his very first day
in office, a memorandum
on transparency and open
government, in which he said
that data data collected
by the government, paid
for by our taxpayer dollars,
collected in the government's
practice as regulator and
as researcher belongs to us.
It was very controversial,
I might add, at the time.
It seems obvious to us now,
but it was very controversial,
the idea that we
weren't simply focusing
on data about the
workings of government,
such as the money that
it spends or the salaries
of public officials.
But that in fact we would try
to open up all the data that
could power things
like the innovations
that we are talking about today.
And then going beyond the
idea of just a policy,
of just words, the creation
of platforms that actually
allow us to put data somewhere.
To have a place for people
to find that data so that we
can go beyond the
promise and make
the practice real in principle.
There's great things
that it's allowing
us to do in terms
of transforming
how government works.
So when they put up the
school spending data in Mexico
on Mejora Tu Escuela,
we can see right away
that 1512 people
all on the payroll,
all have the same birthdate.
They're all 102 years
old and they all
make more than the
president of Mexico.
So it allows us to yes, improve
government accountability,
but it also in the end allows
parents to make better choices.
And ultimately, it's not
a story about the data
and it's not a story
about the platforms,
even as we know and as
you so well pointed out,
it's about the communities
that we build around the data.
So in Rajasthan in
India, the group MKSS
has for the last decade been
taking government spending
data, budget data, and painting
it on the walls of villages.
And holding readings,
theatrical performances,
in which they read the budget.
If that doesn't sound exciting,
I don't know what does.
[LAUGHTER]
But what they do is
then they ask people
where is the bridge
built to nowhere?
Where is the person who's died
who's still on the payroll?
And through that mechanism,
using data as the raw material,
co-create the process
and the practice
of greater accountability
in government.
So I want to just spend
a couple of minutes
on talking about another
sort of development.
You're all very familiar
with kind of the movement
around open data.
The one, though, that I want
to emphasize that we have
to continue to fight for,
we cannot, especially now,
take it as a given or
take it for granted,
the two leading countries,
the US and the UK,
that spearheaded this movement
have both had a change
of administration, neither of
which seem poised to invest
in this agenda.
That's a best case scenario
is that they ignore it.
But we all know
that the reality is
that we might see significant
rollbacks on the opening
up of data and
investments in open data
since it costs real
money to actually do it.
What we are seeing,
though, is a rise
of what many people call social
corporate data philanthropy
or what we call
data collaboratives.
Bloomberg just had a
big conference on data
science for social good in which
many companies came, committing
to open up their data.
And we know that part of the
clinical trial story, part
of what so many people in this
room have been fighting for,
is to not only get the
clinical trials data from NIH,
but to also get it directly
from the companies that
are producing this data.
So, it's Twitter providing
its fire hose of data
to the University of Wollongong
in Australia and then using
that, the university using that
to create flood maps to help
promote resilience-- excuse me--
in Indonesia.
So we're seeing lots of ways in
which open data, including data
that comes from government, data
that comes from researchers,
data that comes from companies,
through collaboration often
between these three parties--
that's what we call
data collaboratives--
it's at that intersection
that a lot of exciting work
is happening.
I only have a few minutes
today to talk about this
so I would point you to a
website that we've created
called OD Impact,
Open Data's Impact,
where we're collecting case
studies and in-depth stories
but also that analysis of
these examples of open data.
We have another
project with USAID
focused on that work in the
development context as well.
That's all going up here.
And I might add to your point,
this is fully open source
and replicable and
a number of people
have already forked this to
create their own archives
and repositories of open
data impact stories.
Since so much of this
work, as you said earlier,
is about telling
the story of impact,
not just talking
about the promise.
So I want to fly through
a couple of examples
that again, I think for
you, this is a room that
needs no convincing.
But I think it's important
to at least share
a little bit of the
story about the ways
in which we are transforming
not only science,
but we're transforming
government and other sectors
through open data.
And then to end with a
couple of just thoughts
on the policy side of this.
So obviously, we can
do lots of great stuff
now in terms of our ability
to provide services,
especially to vulnerable people,
by monitoring populations
in real time.
So when we open up things
like the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric data,
we can do things
like better predict the weather.
And a lot of that data,
though, some of it's
coming from the government
as we know, but some of that
data also then comes
from companies.
So it's Intel opening up
data that collects off
of sensors that it's using.
And the combination
of data is allowing
us to create new tools that
help to promote resilience.
We can, as we saw with the
Mejora Tu Escuela example,
also improve how government
spends money and government
efficiency and
government effectiveness.
As was mentioned, I'm on
the board of a nonprofit
called the Open
Contracting Partnership
which works with
governments around the world
to open up their contracting
and spending data.
By the way, the data is open
but we need people to look at it
and use it if we're going to
actually spot the fraud, waste,
and abuse.
At the very least,
what it's starting
to do is to decrease a
culture of corruption
in places like Slovakia, the
Ukraine, which interestingly
is very out ahead in last
year on open contracting data,
and Mexico and elsewhere.
But we're seeing this
move towards government
using its own data to
actually decrease its spending
and become more accountable.
We're seeing then, of
course, the ability
to use this data to solve
major social problems.
So we have problems
hiding in plain sight
like that in Zanesville,
Ohio where when you actually
scrutinize the data, you
discover that clean water is
being delivered.
There's a red lining problem.
If you live in a
neighborhood that is white,
you're receiving
clean city water.
If you live in a neighborhood
that's traditionally
African-American, you are not.
This led to then a
lawsuit, a change
in the situation, damages
that were paid to the victims.
But it would not have been
possible without open data
about city water services,
about city water practices that
allow us then to spot
this kind of unfairness
and to rectify major
social problems.
And so we're also
seeing, obviously, lots
of use of data collection.
And this is
particularly important
where citizen science
comes in, in terms
of using people on the
ground as data collectors.
We're seeing incidentally a
lot of that use of citizens
as data collectors
now as monitors
of rises of hate incidents
and bias incidents,
as you've seen lots of
efforts by different groups
to collect data about
hate crimes and rises
of incidents of hate
that are occurring.
So the collection of data,
particularly by citizens,
that we can use when made
open as Christchurch,
New Zealand did to be able then
to figure out which buildings
are about to fall down, where
can people move back in,
how do we actually
rebuild the city?
So the CIO of
Christchurch, New Zealand
was in fact very out
ahead on using open data.
And then that collaboration
and partnership
with citizens, both
to collect the data
but also to scrutinize the data
to be able to develop solutions
in real time.
And again, what you see is a
lot of this work happening now
at the intersection
between government
and private companies.
Because especially in a lot
of developing world contexts,
there is no administrative
state infrastructure.
There isn't that data being
collected by government.
And so, we need to depend on the
work of groups like Real Impact
Analytics and Twitter and
others who have the data
and push them to
make it available so
that we can do this
kind of social good work
more efficiently
and effectively.
My lab has a
partnership with UNICEF.
Over the next year and a
half, we'll be working--
we have both work to
define the problems
that UNICEF works on in terms
of improving children's lives.
And then trying to find the
partners that we can turn to
in countries that don't have a
census, that don't have a data
collection infrastructure,
or where we might A,
create one using
citizen scientists or B,
use data that companies
are anyway collecting.
Finally, the last example
that I want to give,
and it's an example
that we frequently
use when we have a hard time
convincing people of the need
to open up their data, we can
see how it works with provosts.
I know how it works with
prime ministers, which
is you tell them not that open
data is the right thing to do,
you don't tell them about
solving social problems
and helping flood victims
and babies and children,
you tell them it'll create jobs
and promote economic growth.
You tell them about how New
York City is using open data
to create a business atlas
that gives the small business
owner the same kind
of market research
information about where
to site their jewelry
store or their coffee shop as
the Starbucks or the Gap has.
We have a project called
the Open Data 500, which
has been tracking--
and this, by the way,
Open Data 500 is
in the US and then
we have a bunch
of other countries
that we're partnered with
labs in other places--
tracking businesses that use
open data to create jobs.
And we're working with scholars
at Columbia Business School
to track the investment
in those businesses.
And their research shows
that in fact, businesses
driven by open data, perhaps
surprisingly, in fact
receive no less investment than
people who used closed assets
and closed resources.
In fact, they do just as well.
And there's a tremendous number
of exciting stories about how
companies-- and back to
your point about creating
the commercial layer on
top of these services--
the fact that in this country,
unlike in many others,
we have a policy which says
you can reuse the data,
including for commercial
purposes, helps to create jobs.
So let me just-- let
me sort of wind up.
I have no idea what time it is.
We have a couple more minutes.
So, ultimately, I think
the biggest benefiT--
and we know this
from the science case
but we also see it as
much in the government
case, both in terms
of reproducibility
in all of these
contexts-- is what
we do is we get more
eyeballs on a problem.
So by opening up the
data, we can then
get-- which one is this one-- we
can then get election watchers.
We can then create a
crowdsourcing project
as the Kawal Pemilu project
did, using open election
data to then--
in a project that I
might add cost something
on the order of $57 and
was done in about a week.
These stories are all so
wonderful about how cheap
they are.
We're then able to
scrutinize election results
for fraud, et cetera.
So let me-- I'm going to
skip ahead because I want
to talk about the challenges.
So how do we realize
this benefit,
whether in the
government context
or in the science context?
Obviously, we need
to continue to push.
And that's part of the--
that's the entire impetus
for this event today.
We need to push for the policies
against data hugging disorder,
against data hoarding disorder.
But we have to do it
in all of these sectors
and we have to do it in
all of them in tandem
because we need the
collaboration between them
if we're to realize the social
benefits from having the data.
So we need to keep pushing
on the government side,
but we need to also do
this work with companies,
with research
institutes, et cetera,
in order to realize
these benefits.
It's not, though, all a
story about open data, right?
And we know very well,
particularly for people
who are doing human
subjects research, who
are doing biomedical
research, this
is also a story about
the Fifty Shades of Gray
in between closed
and open, namely,
responsible data access
and data governance.
Knowing how to share data in
reliable and responsible ways.
So I was very proud that
my students yesterday
got to present a poster
on work that they're
doing with two jurisdictions now
in Lafayette Parish, Louisiana
and Codington County, South
Dakota on their governance
practices for sharing data
between their criminal justice
and mental health agencies.
Helping them to work
through that process
and develop a tool
kit and kind of a map
for how to do that so they can
in turn reduce incarceration
by diverting the mentally
ill out of jail or prison
and into treatment.
That can only be done
through data sharing.
But that has to be
done in ways that
are legally compliant, that
are ethically compliant,
where they actually know
what IT to use unlike one
of the jurisdictions
which simply emails
a spreadsheet of everybody from
one agency to another, which
we know is not the
best way to do it.
So there's a whole
range of issues
that intertwine the
technical and the legal
and the ethical that are really
questions of data governance
that are at the center
of a lot of the work
that we see happening.
There's fabulous work being
done now by the UN's Food Lab
and the UN hunger
program collecting
data about Syrian refugees
and their consumption of food
in the camps.
But they can't simply publish
and visualize this data
lest they make
the people they're
trying to help potential
targets and victims of crime
and attack.
So there are lots of
difficult ethical questions
that people are debating.
And in this country
where we have launched--
we announced it last year
and about 120 years days ago,
the checks were dispersed in the
Precision Medicine Initiative--
we have this great
hope that we will
start to collect longitudinal
data from a million people
not just about their
genetics, but now
about their cultural practices,
their environmental practices,
what they do.
And to do that data, to
collect it effectively,
we have to know responsibly
how to handle it.
It's great if we
have 10 years of data
on people that can allow us
to quickly spot that I might
be at the risk of diabetes.
But it's terrible if by
virtue of that surveillance,
I suddenly start getting
coupons for Big Macs.
Then we're doing
something wrong.
We're doing something
wrong if we're not then
also putting the people at
the center of the process
and ensuring that
in that research,
we are prioritizing the
needs and the conditions
of the people who
are most underserved
and underrepresented
in biomedical research.
I'm glad to report that in the
Precision Medicine Initiative,
they have taken extra steps
to create a national level
IRB with a high degree of
diversity in that IRB to ensure
exactly that, that
people and their privacy
is being put at the center.
So let me stop--
because I want to make
sure we have some
time for questions--
and just say that as we talk
about all the fabulous things
that we can do with big
data in the sciences,
that we must put the policies
of privacy, of openness,
of ethical and responsible
sharing, and of governance
at the center.
And so with all that, I
make a case for the lawyers
and why we're very happy to
be part of this conversation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]